are we excited chat
are we excited we gonna see the map go
boom
oh
i don't know what everyone's predictions
are what's gonna happen to the map
oh we excited chat
oh
we're gonna we're gonna play a little uh
war zone as a warm-up
maybe this is the last time we'll see
the map in its current glory so i figure
we'll play 30 minutes and then on the
dot
we are going to switch over
how's everyone doing hell you're excited
i tell you hyped
is gonna go boom no boom i don't know
nothing
i'm i'm very ready
for more numbers mason means as well
the one thing one thing i hope for uh
for cold war more the numbers
that's when it starts it starts in 29
minutes that's the in-game event
so got a chance to grab some snacks
get a get comfortable
i'm excited i'm very keen cold war
black ops 1 one of the best call of duty
campaigns and settings
in my honest opinion
you like you like captain price's gun
you right
very kawaii
the numbers mason what do they mean god
remember the first time you played black
ops and you could
like wiggle out of your chair in the
main menu
incredible
that's that's one of the ogs how to beat
that honestly
very very fond memories of that game
except for
everything except the g11
and the zombies
playing as a jfk and castro
and uh
chat help me out who's the who's the
fourth player in in blocks on zombies
i'm not gonna i'm not the creator of
gamespot now
one of their humble events that work
there
your primary objective is to kill them
all
mcnamara yeah it was mcnamara you're
right
oh great start the
event is happening in 26 minutes
but i get that looking sharper though
as far as i know we'll just we'll get an
opportunity to
jump into the event but i'm i'm gonna
jump out of the game
like 29 minutes
and then jump in and see what happens
you're up soldier
all of yous tuning in from your online
classes
go get your learning on
okay
now the reveal reveals in 25. i i will
double check just for you chat
i will double check what the
situation is do i need to be in a new
game or will it just
i'm hoping i'm hoping there's just a big
opening is just a big bang
run it back
what do you think gonna be some of the
new battlefields in call of duty old war
well because i mean it was like a
promising thing really
look quite a lot i'm guessing there'll
be something in berlin i really like the
black ops 1 berlin wall map
that was really cool um so i hope they
do something like that again
i don't think they're called peasants
think they're called children
watch the skies
all right that's enough [ __ ] about
now we do this for real
run it back
i'm double checking but i think you just
have to be in war zone for it to happen
zone
where haven't we gone for a while
anyway it's been a minute since i've
played uh
ozone i must admit
get to work
well you had some shotguns huh
i see you chat
i think i don't i know your memes
hey that's very rude
all right so it looks like the plan is
that you need to back out of the game
and you need to be on the
main menu the war zone sort them out
and then you'll be able to end the event
from there
so around 10 30 there should be a
playlist refresh
and then you can enter whatever the
event is
that i wanted to assassinate him
oh bless him
so a tweet just went out from
about the event so from that it looks
like you just need to be
in the menu and oh my game crashed
you need to be in the menu and playlist
will refresh
if i hear news things change
i'll let you know bear with you
every snippet yeah
yeah expect a playlist update at 10 30
pt across all platforms
so we'll back out at like 29 minutes
and then we'll
joe why did you crash my game
oh big rig did i
butterfingers
it's obviously just salty that i didn't
get take down that guy
i get my map odin that's all i want
ask
i hope the one of the things i miss
about black ops is
sticks and stones game mode six and
stones and one in the chamber
that great time
eamon my favorite gun is the odin long
gross ode
looks fake feel enough when you get shot
by it fam
sounds like someone breaking in
come down nick down
i'm right baruto's dad
no target practice believe your name is
if you want to know when joe is ask joe
mama
is that what you wanted from me chat you
happy now
it's
ac 130 above
apparently even there is a playlist
update
at 10 30 pt
don't be in the lobby the menu
in 15 minutes quarter of an hour as we
say in the uk
royale you've got gas closing in fast
get to the safe zone
oh oh it's not really what i wanted
i'm assuming the war zone menu i believe
it's the war zone menu but we'll double
check as we go
you know about as much as i do chat
oh shoot from that guy
wait a second how did you know i was up
there
oh it's up there
battlefield hanging out in the kremlin
like it's uh
issued impossible
get yourself sorted you're up next
listen up soldier win here and you
return to the front line
but if you lose you're gone time to earn
your freedom soldier
the game's a touch laggy probably
because everyone wants to get in for the
event
i am aaron that is that is me that is
who i am
[Music]
youtube
close it's 4 8 15 16 23 42
i believe that's the numbers from lost
not
oh did i open the door
it's
that fascinated me when i was nice to
play black ops one
been able to put different commands into
the computer and unlock that weird top
down
game
i hope they do stuff like that again
really weird args
i mean starkiller you don't have to i
understand
positive id on the bounty target sort
them out
oh there's a red dot over there screw
the bounty
that's why you're watching me play
warzone the the secret is that if you
pre-order cold war you get me
as a pre-order skin
10 minutes shout you hype
blank blank you relax you'll see it when
it's ready
wait like the rest you come over there
i look like frank woods thank you
i'll take that
enemy uav overhead
up
yeah they're scared of us that's why
that's why i can't find anyone
intimidated by power
i guess they weren't that intimidated
hey you'd have to line up the station at
the station at the stadium
it'll um you'll need to be on the main
menu and um
update the playlist at the warzone
lobby
play this one last time all right you
better listen up
listen up
jager don't you give me advice you
wrapping things in siege
just gotta be in the lobby
grab some target practice while you can
we're deploying
let's get it ice cold
gonna get you oh you got me
five minutes chat
battle royale gas is approaching your
position move to the safe zone
be more decisive when i choose my
landing spot
where'd he go
found him
oh my god
this is the wars this is the cold war
gameplay
what happens
oh my god he moved creepy as hell
wacky wavelength inflatable i'm playing
shoot man
here that we need right now in 2020
anyway i've got my i've got my eye on
the clock
i'm gonna back out him in i'm just gonna
back out now
now we gotta wait
so apparently there's going to be a
playlist update
we just wait wait and see if the
playlist update comes
but now you can admire
my my big gun like it
that my big
read the call of duty twitter my my
friends there's going to be a playlist
update
but brad
we wait for the playlist update
all right there should be a playlist
update any second
do a refresh we're updating we're
updating
it's all good
delete system32 real quick
shadow plays sunny to relax
i have to wait 17.
there he's in it
we're connecting come on war zone i
believe in you
everyone share your energy and we'll get
in quick
believe me chat i'm as good as you are
that the servers are choosing now to
pack in
so
this means just means that the reveal
will be all this
oh
nearly progress
right here
let's go let's go chat know your history
right on i will
get ready get ready it's just one more
loading screen and then
we're good
come on game stop teasing me like this
stop it
all right what's the what's the score
give it to me oh
again redacted
what
oh i just oh this is the pre-match
there's a pre-match to it what on earth
i'll wait for the lobby to fill oh my
god this is such a team
what does steps to freedom mean
this is black ops 1 music in the
background i think
yeah this is totally black ops 1 music
amazing
this this track is filling me with
nostalgia
holy bridge
ten more and then the lobby's full and
it'll get underway
enemy trucks
let's go
every journey begins with a single step
this is step one right so we have to
collect the map code secure the key
crack the map code and wield the weapon
oh my gosh
do and kill intel all right
let's get it
oh i spawned with my gun
i didn't expect to spawn with my own gun
all right then
ain't gonna is
ah heck nervous chat
so hyped for this oh what is happening
too spooky for me
let's run the hunt for map codes i guess
it's a numbers for a chili's gift card
if only
oh no
i'm thoroughly enjoying all the black
ops one lines in check
yeah there's the servers uh getting hit
hard so i'm
not surprised things are lagging a
little
fine i got all those kills but i wasn't
able to pick up any intel
all right i got one piece of intel
servers do be taking a hammer into the
area watch the skies
how are you not getting shot
days away though
oh yeah the map the map db oh my days
cia's coming for me chap
take my aim but off absolutely not i
paid good money for the same boat
i looked at the map look it's redacted
it do be spooky
the spookiest of call of duty times
it's right you'll keep me safe chap i
believe in you
[Music]
every time you go into new era oh god
that's made me jump every time so far
very inconsiderate
other servers be sluggish
some ominous as hell music as well
it looks like this i just noticed as a
timer above 8 47 so i'm guessing
something else will happen
in eight minutes
unlucky mate
all right we've got five pieces of intel
first step to freedom complete secure
the key
i just ditched my chopper
now let me know if you see a car
i said we'll jog it
yeah quiet what's next game tell me
unlock the cash
my chat help me find the cash
oh my god right you are right armor
so focus on the
primary objective accomplished all
supply boxes found
it's happening
wield the weapon
h2 h
was quarry
sorry family got time
one over
one little truck put your foot down
there's loads of other players
oh get out of here
my turn
here right it's been some time since i
played warzone you gotta help
are we going gamers
the music though
that's the main draw
[Music]
[Laughter]
where am i going chad that's a good
question
h2 it's hd
i don't know where the the nuke is
the bunker is
i think the uh the puzzle is only for um
collectibles anyway so don't worry about
it too much
ah
he was hiding in here all along chat
just woods hanging out
hope you'll get a good look at him there
ascension
one uh-oh
25 6 13
6 7 15
14 0.
tapping shop
i understand what's going on around you
you are in a state of war
and you have precious little time to
save yourself
oh gotta get to the stadium
chat we gotta run gotta run
now everything's in russian there's a
slow process
which we call active measures
amazing
it takes from 15 to 20 years to
demoralize the nation
the next stage is destabilization
what matters is essentials economy
foreign relations defense systems
oh my god this is incredible
someone better not punch me
is
whoa
this war was a lie
years of a secret war
decades
five days ago we acquired intel
soviet agent perseus is in play
this looks amazing berlin wall let's go
something that could shift the balance
of the cold war
is that woods right let's go find this
[ __ ]
possibly's back let's go
is the threat real
yes sir we believe it is give mr adler
whatever he wants
look how good nixon looks
that was nixon
i know you won't fail us
back to vietnam get early access to the
open beta incredible
modern warfare look it's me
this is a new warzone map
that time a night
holy heck
out with our good friend ronald reagan
i don't know who american
what's the rewards we got amazing
there you have it chat and you can play
it all over again
incredible incredible
no no you can't play over again you just
uh
get taken to pre-order all right well
that's a lot of fun i'm super excited uh
if you want to see the full uncut thing
you it'll be
on our youtube channel right now um so
you can see it all in all of its clean
unstreamed glory
um but thanks for hanging out
like you can play again but i think we
need to
i'm going to sign off so you guys can
jump in the game see it for yourself and
experience the hype uh thank you for
hanging out go on to gamespot to
watch the full uncut version
oh i'm so excited what numbers mason
what do they mean
what do they mean